the US's vaccine program is the Envy of
much of the world with over 3 million
people getting the jab every day
but the virus continues to spread
quickly
States like Michigan are especially hard
hit
causing some to call for tough medicine
summer and to shut things down
with seventy thousand new infections
each day vaccines alone might not be
enough to turn the tide in the fight
against covert 19.
no other country in the world has been
hit harder by the coronavirus the United
States has had the most confirmed cases
and deaths in the world and despite its
unprecedented vaccination program those
numbers are still Rising
many people have grown weary of lockdown
and with warming weather many states
have lifted restrictions
facing the threat of a fourth wave
President Joe Biden's Administration is
doubling down on vaccination as the key
to ending the pandemic but local
outbreaks threaten to undo that strategy
John Brooks joins us from the CDC the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention how would you say the U.S is
coming along there's there's been a
change in leadership a change in the
weather but has there been progress in
the fight against covert
well I think there has been steady
progress in the fight against covet even
since we began and this is despite three
waves including a really unprecedented
uh third wave over the holiday season
but we're coming down off the back of
that wave right now and really getting
the numbers down quickly we're not
seating yet I mean we're making
incredible progress but the number of
new infections we're seeing in this
country remains about what it was during
our second wave last summer so about 50
000 new infections a day and five to
five hundred to one thousand deaths a
day
suddenly they're promising when you take
a look at who's been inoculated a third
of the population has got at least one
jab that's over 120 million Americans
but with the focus on getting people
vaccinated what about new restrictions
on the economy because there's a new
wave of coronavirus cases as you
mentioned and hospitals are getting
crowded
that's right and this you know we want
to reserve using those really most
difficult decisions of shutting down the
economy to when we have to apply them
but it's becoming apparent that we may
be at a place where in some
jurisdictions certain States it may be
time to sort of shut down a little bit
to gain control over this virus I mean
we're in a big race right now right we
are racing against the virus with
vaccine and we've got to get the vaccine
out as soon as possible we're asking
people to hold on a little bit longer we
know it's frustrating it's been a rough
year people want to get back to the
normal life they enjoyed before but
we're not done with this race we're not
done with the battle and we're going to
have to hang on till we can really get
vaccination out but John is that message
getting through to State officials
because in Michigan the State Health
director says the government's focusing
on getting more people vaccinated rather
than imposing new restrictions on the
economy
well it would be wonderful if
vaccination took effect immediately but
you know it takes a couple of weeks for
you to be to benefit from vaccination uh
with uh the um Beyond Tech vaccine it's
21 days between doses plus another 14
days until you're fully covered but
they're seeing a problem right now and
to deal with the problem right now you
need to cut off the chains of
transmission with whatever you have at
your disposal and unfortunately at this
time the best means for that would be
slowing down on the reopening of society
there so which states would you say are
getting it right which are getting it
wrong because again despite all those
vaccinations the the seven day case rate
per 100 000 people is at 515 in Michigan
California's only at 50.
that's right and it's interesting it's
also very low in I believe States like
Texas and Florida where one might have
expected you know that it would be um
higher so where we don't understand
exactly why the rates are different in
different states it's probably some
combination of the fact that some states
have gotten more vaccine out they have
more social distancing measures still in
place the
um government and political opinion is
aligned with public health so we're all
singing from the same song book we say
right that we are all working together
and not against each other what about
herd immunity is there going to be a
stage where the U.S will reach that
yeah I I mean it I have an infectious
disease doctor I've been working in this
area for 30 years and I'm certain that
we will reach herd immunity I just don't
know what that number is we'll know it
when we get there because there will be
a sustained Decline and then leveling
off of new infections and that will be
the point when there have been enough
people vaccinated as well unfortunately
as people who've recovered from illness
that the virus can't find anywhere else
to go and and that also depends upon
whether or not the virus manages to
mutate in a in a certain direction
that's absolutely right we're watching
that very carefully I mean these
mutations uh concern these variants
they're called really concern us a lot
and vigilance really matters when
viruses vary
so we've uh put in oh I'm sorry go ahead
that's okay what were you going to say
I say we've put into place a very very
uh large National effort to routinely
screen a large number of these uh
viruses now to monitor for variants and
to identify those mutations which either
make the virus more transmissible may
increase the severity or undercut some
of the activity of drugs that we use
against the virus okay on on that very
topic I wanted to just mention some
Americans are already getting a third
dose which will be used to some people
around the world they're they're taking
part in a study of updated versions of
the coronavirus vaccines and they've
been tweaked to tackle mutations of the
virus a variant discovered in Britain
just months ago is already the most
common version of the coronavirus
circulating in the United States current
vaccines offer strong protection against
these mutations but researchers want to
be ready to respond to new threats that
emerge of course that study is being run
by the National Institute of Health and
Emory University in a enter I believe
John which is where you're based these
sorts of tweaks can be achieved in in a
matter of weeks it's The Regulators that
hold back the process by months can and
and should that be changed
well I think there'll be a lot of
urgency to find a pathway forward where
we can make these changes these and
adopt these regulatory changes as
rapidly as we possibly can while of
course maintaining the safety of the
public who will be receiving these
vaccines you know we have annual flu
vaccination now in that case every year
the World Health Organization and other
public health organizations around the
world look ahead as to what may be
coming but we have a different situation
now we have these mRNA vaccines from
Beyond Tech and moderna and other
companies that you can
custom create the vaccine with mRNA
relatively quickly and then it takes
probably weeks to a few months to get
that into production I believe that
given the experience with this pandemic
we're going to hopefully see Regulators
moving just as quickly with us
that's uh that would be nice John uh can
you can you can you give us is there is
there anything else that you can leave
us with uh that gives us some sort of
Hope in this crisis
well I'll just say this I mean Our Food
and Drug Administration is the
organization in charge of these
regulations and they've they have
experienced this pandemic just like we
have at our agency which uh is in charge
of things related to prevention and I
think that there is a strong desire to
move forward into this future in a way
that we can keep the public safe but
respond more fleetly we've had some bad
experiences where we weren't able to
respond as quickly as we'd like and it's
clear that that's going to be an
important thing in the future John
Brooks from the CDC thank you very much
for joining us today
it's my pleasure
in another setback the United States has
recommended putting the Johnson Johnson
vaccine on halt it's investigating a
potential link between the jab and blood
clots nearly 7 million people have
received a single dose vaccine in the
U.S clotting was reported in Six Women
in the days after vaccination
several countries have also restricted
the AstraZeneca shot over clotting fears
over to our science correspondent Derek
Williams who has an interesting viewer
question about the vaccine and
hospitalizations
foreign
[Music]
how come people hospitalize with
covid-19 don't get the vaccine couldn't
it save their lives no although ongoing
Research into what are called
therapeutic vaccines is fascinating the
approved covid vaccines are traditional
in in the sense that they aren't
therapies if you already have covid-19
they're a measure to prevent you from
Contracting it in the first place or at
least ensuring that if you do get the
disease it'll be a milder case and you
won't end up in the hospital the reason
the pandemic went Global so fast and
spun so quickly out of control is
because Stars Kobe 2 was a novel
pathogen that no one had been exposed to
before a state that experts call being
immunologically naive the vaccines now
in use basically teach your body that
there's a bad bug out there that looks
like this so that if it shows up in your
nose or throat you your immune system is
is forewarned and can jump on it quickly
but just like it takes time for your
immune system to respond if you're
infected for real it also takes time to
ramp up an immune response to the fake
infection that a vaccine simulates a
couple of weeks give or take a few days
depending on the vaccine so so giving
someone who has a severe case of the
disease a vaccine won't help and could
likely do harm that's why trusted Health
Care authorities like the Centers for
Disease Control recommend that if you
have covid-19 you need to wait a while
after your symptoms have completely
subsided before you even begin to
consider getting vaccinated
[Music]
finally surging coronavirus cases in
many parts of the world are
overshadowing the start of Ramadan South
Asia's nations are battling a spiraling
outbreak Europe has passed a million
deaths the Muslim holy month is a time
of avoiding food and drink during the
day and coming together for feasts at
night both a challenge during the
pandemic Indonesia has the world's
biggest Muslim population and people
have been attending socially distant
services in mosques it's Islamic body
now says covert vaccinations do not
violate the fast and are permissible
under the religious law a relief for the
government which has been counting on a
vaccine drive to tackle the largest
number of infections and deaths in
Southeast Asia
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
[Music]